- [Jay] Good to see you.
It's been a while.
- Yes, it's been awhile.
Good to see you.
- Now, how's the family?
You've had more kids.
How many kids do you have now?
- I got three kids.
- Okay.
- I have a 26-year-old
and a 12-year-old boy.
26-year-old is a girl, 10-year-old girl,
- Oh, okay.
So took a little break there?
- Yeah.
(Johnny laughs)
- Yeah, took a little time off.
- [Jay] Oh gosh, look at the time fly.
Yeah, well it's so...
Wow, okay so...
Well, there's 10 years
between myself and my brother
so actually that's not
that unusual to me but--
- Yeah, same with my sisters.
They're eight and 10 years older.
- [Jay] Right, right.
- Yeah.
- [Jay] And of course,
we were all planned.
- [Johnny] Oh, yeah.
(woman laughs)
- [Johnny] Well, I can't
tell you what my father
said about that cause
this is daytime television
but yes we were not planned.
- [Jay] We were not planned.
- [Jay] Now, any signs
that the children are going
the "Jackass" route?
Has the gene literally
fallen from the tree?
It hit them in the head, do you know?
- Luckily my daughters
that gene didn't get passed
down to them.
They're so...
You know girls are just smarter
than boys and I don't have
to worry about them but my
son is just like my father.
So he's got that funny
look in his eye and yeah
so I have to worry about Rocco.
- [Jay] Both pupils in the
same eye, that kind of thing?
(audience laughs)
- [Johnny] Yeah, yeah.
We shouldn't have named
him Rocco, you know?
- [Jay] Oh, is that his name, Rocco?
- [Johnny] Yeah, yeah.
- [Jay] Now why Rocco?
That's an old fashioned name.
My dad was like in his 40's
when I was born but his best
friend when he was a kid
was a guy named Rocco.
That's the only Rocco I ever knew.
Why Rocco?
- We just love that name.
You know it's like an old
throwback, tough guy name.
- [Jay] Right, right.
- So yeah we liked it.
- [Jay] Gee hard to
believe the kid is going
the same route, yeah.
(Johnny laughs)
- We should have named a Murray
from accounting or something.
- [Jay] Yeah Murray, Murray.
Murray is a good, nice, solid name.
Who goes with Rocco?
You have hitman that's available
and Lefty is probably taken.
- [Johnny] Yeah, yeah.
- [Jay] But Rocco just seems
like somebody that would be
in the Barzini family.
(Johnny laughs)
- You Know one of those kinds of--
- Working with Clemenza?
- Yeah, exactly.
Now as you were growing
up did the children know
what daddy did or did he think you were
in insurance sales or something?
- Yeah, they didn't know what I did.
- [Jay] Right.
- So it was to the point where Rocco,
he was like six or seven and
we're sitting down for dinner
one night and he just
blurts out, "Jackass."
And we're like, "Whoa."
It seemed like there was a
secret we were keeping from him.
I guess his buddies at school
had told him something about
it and we'd never brought it up because--
- [Jay] Gee, how'd they figured that out?
Gosh.
- I didn't want him to see it right until
he's much older so--
- Like what, 35?
- Yeah, 35 you know.
So I had to tell him that dad
has a silly show where he does
pranks and stunts and but--
- Now was that what you
said dad has a silly show
where he does...
It's so funny how you justify
stuff to kids 'cause before
(Jay mumbles)
Hit the guy with a bottle and then--
The cops chased me and I punched the cop.
Well we had a funny thing with the police.
(Audience laughs)
(Johnny laughs)
I like how you just water it down.
- There's a lot of tomfoolery
- [Jay] Lot of tomfoolery?
Jim Crackery?
Yes, that type of thing.
Yeah, exactly.
So now what's your son shocked
to learn that their dad
was an idiot?
(Johnny laughs)
- Well, he was disappointed
but he wasn't surprised Jay.
- [Jay] Right, okay.
'Cause he knew, "Oh, the gene."
- Yeah.
Well, I think it's cool that you produce,
write and do these movies yourself.
I mean it's crazy stuff
but crazy like a fox
'cause you're pretty much
the whole movie company,
aren't you?
- Well me and my partners, Spike Jones
and Jeff Tremaine, we all do it ourselves.
- [Jay] Right, but you know what it mean?
It's one of those things
where Warner Brothers gets
2% and somebody of the studio gets 9%
and you know what I mean?
Those things so you can pretty much...
You know where all the money goes.
- Yeah, if you're gonna
wreck yourself you might
as well get paid for it.
- [Jay] Right, exactly.
- You know.
(Johnny laughs)
- Exactly, exactly.
Okay, so what can we expect?
I know we can expect to see this movie.
(audience laughs)
(Johnny laughs)
But tell me some more.
- Oh my goodness.
Well, there's fun with bulls.
There's always a bull.
It's probably the worst
bull hit I've ever taken.
Spent a weekend in the hospital.
- So no bull?
- Yeah, no bull you know what.
Everything you see is real.
That's one thing we have on our
side in the "Jackass" movies
it's the truth.
- Well, see that's a good
'cause in most Hollywood films
they'd be a stuntman or a sensible person
doing some sort of CGI.
- [Johnny] Right.
- You actually kill the people?
- Yeah no, we wreck the guys.
They don't know what's
coming when they walk on set
so by the end of the film
they're suffering from PTSD.
They are like...
- [Jay] Right.
- You can walk up behind
someone and just put your finger
on their shoulder and they'll go down.
- Right, just because--
- [Johnny] They're in terror.
- Now you come from a family--
- I'd like to say I feel bad but I don't.
(Johnny laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Was your dad a prankster?
I mean--
- Oh my God.
- Is this where it came from?
- My dad owned a tire shop
and he was more interested
in pranking his employees
than running the shop.
- [Jay] Right.
- He would make them Ex-Lax milkshakes,
he would--
- [Jay] Ex-lax milkshakes?
- Yes, as some kind of reward.
He got in trouble for this with,
I don't know if it was the
Tennessee bureau of investigation
or the FBI he would send
out letters from the IRS
to his buddy saying,
"They're about to be audited
and they have to get all
"their papers together."
And like people really freaked out.
You know no one wants that letter.
- And they take that stuff seriously.
When I was a kid for for
Christmas holiday my parents gave
me a printing set where
you could make a little...
You can put the letters,
make your own stamps.
- [Johnny] Right.
- And I made one that said,
"FBI, top secret."
(Johnny laughs)
So I put it on...
I wrote a letter to my
dad and put it on the,
I stamped it and put a stamp
on it and I went down the post
office and threw it on the
floor to see what would happen.
About three days later
black sedan comes in,
FBI guy, postal
"Mr. Leno letter from the FBI.
"We did not wanna open this.
"It says top secret."
And my father goes "Top secret,"
and then he knew that was my thing.
- How old Were you when you did that?
- Oh, I had 12, 13.
- [Johnny] That's pretty great.
- Oh yeah, and my parents were like,
m dad was furious.
- [Johnny] Oh yeah, you got in trouble.
- "Mr. Leno we didn't want to open it.
"It says FBI," but we
found that out on the floor
of the post office.
(Johnny laughs)
"We don't know how that could
have happened, we apologize."
You know they're apologizing.
- [Johnny] Right, right.
- For my Dad's top secret letter.
- Oh man, that's a good one.
- [Jay] Yeah, I was pretty good.
- That's pretty good.
- So did your dad have a crew like you do?
(Johnny laughs)
Did he have a--
- Oh boy did he?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, there's Big Sam, Big
George, Ass Kicking Robert.
I don't know if he can
say that but they can...
- Well, if it's a legal name.
- Yes, it was on his driver's license.
- You can call him A.K. Roberts.
- Yeah, and my favorite was
a guy named Woodrow Wilson
Boxcar Johnson Jr.
He was a tire groover at the tire shop--
- A tire groover?
- Yeah, 'cause he...
Dad sold retreads.
- Oh those are so illegal now.
You know what they use to do?
You get a ball tire.
- Yeah.
If somebody is throwing it away
then you got a hot gun and you would--
- [Johnny] Curve groove.
- You'd curve tread into
it so it looked like,
"Ooh look, there's plenty
of tread left in this tire."
- Well yeah, there was barely any.
- There was nothing in that tread.
- That was Boxcar's job.
And then I would paint...
I would get to go to the shop sometimes
and after you've groove them
you would paint them black
to make 'em look new.
So I would get to do that sometimes.
It's always important to have
good role models for a child.
(Johny laughs)
And I think--
- Oh Boxcar is the best.
- It's good to see that this...
You got A.K and Boxcar and yeah.
Now normally in a family
like this there'd be a female
influence like a mom
who is a sensible one.
I'm assuming that probably
didn't take place either
or was your mom the sensible one?
- Mom was probably more of
a wild card than my father.
- Really?
- Yeah.
I mean she was super loving and nurturing
but she had a little switch
where it would go off like--
- I think that's called a
screw loose medical terms.
(Johnny laughs)
- A screw--
- The medical term is a screw loose.
- That's me trying to
put things nicely again.
- Nicely, yeah.
(Johnny laughs)
- There was a big gang fight uptown once
and she had my younger sister...
I wasn't even born yet.
She had my sisters,
We were probably 10 and
12 in the back of the car
and there was a big gang
fight chains, everything
And these guys were going at it.
And mom sees this happening
and she drives right
in the middle of the gang fight
and she gets out of the car
she's like, "You boys are acting ugly.
"You stop that right now."
(audience laughs)
And they were...
Those guys were so confused
that this woman had driven
in the middle of the gang
fight beeping on her horn--
- With the kids in the back?
- Yeah, and they were like...
They just kind of dropped
their chains and walked away.
(audience laughs)
She's crazier than we are.
- [Jay] Yeah.
You know I'm beginning
to understand Johnny more
now that we've talked.
(Johnny laughs)
Finding the reasons why
things are the way they are.
All right, your real name
is not Johnny Knoxville
these are--
- Philip John Clap.
- Philip John Clap?
- Clap, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Now was that based on?
- Yeah, I know.
I get it.
My letters and jackets
said clap on the back
and when I wore that to the
mall you know I heard it.
- [Jay] Okay, this is not
based on the condition
that you had--
- Yeah, no, no.
- Yeah, okay.
And where was...
Is this in Kentucky?
- Tennessee.
- Tennessee, hard to believe.
- Yeah, who knew?
(Jay laughs)
Who knew?
- I mean who expects something
like that in Tennessee.